in the three-point line getting some
benefit from their penetration
blue/black by Alan on Blake Griffin dunk
try but he's showing us an explosiveness
off the first step that he's going to
need like what I've seen as well out of
bounds play still plenty of basketball
left however 6756 blocked by Amazon Luke
Bernard inside whoa great block by Alan
on Andre he'll step back and fire no
Blake Griffin's all right close it look
at Jared Allen he's gonna deny Lou
canard and even more impressively every
player top to bottom you start to see
his the net builder roster fires it down
with two hands Hawks have passed from
Paris a beautiful job
fake tie goes low from places on the
floor Dinwiddie creeps to the corner but
finishes ferociously
and just a strong guide by Jared Allen
additional time because of the injuries
that we brought up corruption gets
gummed hard get his hands up but this is
the strength this is the muscle he put
on because he was able to keep his body
straight up
I mean Blake Griffin was coming at him
Russell gives it up work it around for
Allen shot clock at seven Russell the
parents out of the uncontested dudes
that's a nice play by D'Angelo Russell
Jones knocks welcome to the NBA look
Russell tough delivery a beautiful job
once again by Jared Allen stuffed the
stat sheet oh yes hundred percent a
little bit here and there that's all oh
[Music]
great stop and go wet Dudley drives nice
the throw runneth over Jared Dudley with
the penetration and Olivia in particular
defense team come on David kick out
Russell will off the line finds Jared
Allen and there is the 16th Nets assist
on 19 meet Oh to head up a follow for
Jared Allen Nets take the lead bring the
offensive glass does a good job of being
quick the step in stays with the play
four seconds left field goes behind the
back field blocked at the buzzer by
Allen and the Nets
hit the brake there's cityedition
uniforms 9 to shoot the Montford
Alice Susan hi
Aaron Allen as he finishes that for 20
points then when he sees that I
connection with Jared Allen that's
played so well tonight control the
action led by as much as 15 why'd he get
to slip away in the fourth quarter the
second back to back sit there go much
needed bucket for the net you going to
hold Allen States in with those five
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
telegraphed grab nuts it away and
Russell's got it that's 12 Utah
turnovers Russell shaken baby
Russell gonna have to make something
happen to to shoot
Russell finds a way he got it off in
time with the left-handed slam on a
gorgeous dime from Russell did what are
using the Allen screen the drive lob and
slam trash fiction Dinwiddie gets his
hit 50 into pain
[Music]
[Applause]
rivers he will have none of that steel
circles ooh brain jr. gets swatted by
dead control Lakers get it up the floor
in a hurry
James just got the King push the pace
big old black by Darren an Oklahoma City
on Monday night done had 12 points seven
assists and four rebounds Allen Kate a
Throwdown was a pretty little late but
how about this Throwdown I mean right
out of the gate and it was a beautiful
pass from rondae hollis-jefferson here's
an opportunity to go upstairs you got to
get it over the big guy to begin with
and look at Jared Allen catch Rock did
try to peddle his way through traffic
here comes the dead of Cobo with the
denial comes up huge straight up the
verticality finds the ball what an
excellent job by Jared Allen and of
course we saw the one he had against
LeBron James his past taken away by
Bledsoe this Milwaukee team so long as
Allen gets let's go from behind just
gobble that one up
Miller using the days of screen there's
the bounce in the push shot in and out
rebounded
[Applause]
he got Davis cleaned steady and just
look at this a flat pudding that is
extremely extremely tough but only a few
players in this league could probably go
do that just to go and get it both
flat-footed yeah his euro-step feels
like it's in slow motion as well they
just took it down on the rim for to
thinking did when he was on the floor
with him and then decided not to dish it
out attacks off there was a little power
play off my goodness
chance to check this out
[Applause]
Gries doesn't know what's coming at
what a beautiful extension Brooklyn
cushions you wonder if you thought about
it there for a quick second
gobbles that up and then kurute still be
able to save but another emphatic
rejection factory that is Jared Allen
that almost looked like a volleyball
spot they had a nice looking way that
they allowed to diminish you want to get
that back finishes it a mammoth hammer
from Jared Allen you'd ask him to dunk
it when you go up soft not anymore
no and he tries to dunk it every single
time and he's got such good touch and
touch around the basket that often times
you would see him try and use that or
use his hook shots but not anymore when
he is near the basket the corner to
Kontest
and then now he's on a recovery mode
he's coming right back in excellent job
nice shine Russell off the mark ooh
roots thought he had the offensive
rebound young nice fake around Harris
traps it inside
Sheen but what continues to impress not
just these blocks scoops it up two
seconds one second to the Jared had a
presence defensively oh yeah he got him
what a block so impressive there was
more resistance there 118 105 Rockets
Allen gets the stepped slaps it down
[Applause]
[Music]
shot clock violation
look at Isaac coming off a 13 and 13
game he's playing with more confidence
to lack Oh Jared Allen finishing that's
his second
as of teammates in tears when a lot of
it has to do with his seduction and how
he is maybe your gives it up Karen Allen
throws it down grateful but he allows
him to play to instruct another block he
gets Middleton on the resume real
Russell short come at Jin burst but this
is a he's blocker think Chris Middleton
was trying to just a great way to kind
of break up your season in the segment's
versus looking at it as like one
daunting 82-game schedule the cutter
Sexton denied by L and the fro gets the
rook he's Joe Harris but look he didn't
learn the first time but he's not
learned second time reload with ten to
shoot Russell trying to turn the corner
lobster
Jared Allen team with little bit a
little bit and then gets dealt here to
Washington on a team that's definitely
going through a transition Jared Allen
the flush that's what they're talking
about just a way to easy flow chatter
asking nearly lost it back door green
denied by the throw to the front board
28 points and they're lost the other
night finds it on the pick-and-roll and
a slam it's Jared Allen gets it start at
the first basket 1715 talent free rein
to the rim at a two-hand slam and that's
exactly what you got it did woody and it
is a great great eye contact by spencer
engines when you have a guy like Jared
Allen that that's got it on the side ten
to shoot
Harris again on the move what a flutter
they go with the fro Jared Allen Watts
Joe going downhill you see Kevin Love
but there's nobody there to crack that
it says he's even gotten stronger in his
ability to finish Russell the cross
[Applause]
move to the wrench here again same play
another pick-and-roll but an earlier
pass and he just goes up and gathers
part part of that watch this the throw
blocks Brandon Knight that's had their
largest lead of 15 getting what he
locked it up talent catches jared allen
big fro finish back your financial
bridge and great job a gerontologist
folks in the vault daily comes apart
it's the healthy stuff that expects a
laugh in right away
go on deli where do you do it he's like
I'm gonna get it oh no I don't want
against Blake Griffin and Griffin one of
10 from the field lob it up
[Applause]
Sharon Ellen with a collective favors on
the role in again Alan stones him he
will have known of Derick favor the wall
his timing straight up get Derrick
Favors out of here that man comes with
some strength and Jared Allen has a
whole lot more of his net in play so
when you run that zone it kind of
confuses the team and a lot of times
causes a turnover UK used to see this in
LA all the time but it was crisp all the
others yes the Baumann has it's you know
what is its remnants but we've seen that
before in this first half and a foul
will get Alan a chance for three-point
play you know here again
Dinwiddie with that nice pass was
waiting right under the basket no one's
putting a body on it and so those are
the type of things
Russell laughs tally who's with shoves
off Paris now in the rejection what a
block from Jared Allen perfect in the
flow with me I think he just does
everything quietly in a way
[Applause]
other side of the basket the reverse
throwdown
and Alan a factor there with his legs
Carol lobs it up
Oh frog finish Jared Allen attack mode
now you can bring my out of it off the
bench you've gone hard is Joan Allen and
it just picked up his first personal
foul
approaching the rim and out of bounds
agos moments ago levert attacking mb
[Applause]
last summer and the penny I think Santos
we didn't think he'd play much at all
this season is Allen catches - a lob
pass for Burt he sees that was getting
even for the Falla deal trust me they
watch that they'll met they'll mix it up
here to us all-star it's a whole
different animal with the guy he's gonna
play Mariah's gonna have the ball in his
hands Allen with a nice backdoor cut off
the inbound pass no net young man
buh-bah an ice age and I'd know of
another fact you know second time
they've learned that yes and I don't
want to say I'd know him but we had him
at the adidas euro camp while they sob
another and be a great Canyon Barry had
a jumper Paul a moment ago and once
again Jared Allen Diop it Murphy with
the putback blocked
Allen what Jared Allen oh man come on
now watch it
Murphy is usually gonna dunk this and
here comes Jeff what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content